both y'all dumb as [ __ ] i want you to
know that you two i'm judging a lot
right now
how long you guys been together
12 years oh
you're married
no
why you got that ring on your finger
that [ __ ] is a promise ring that's just
a long ass promise
you're engaged oh okay you can say that
huh
oh you're not engaged
[Applause]
it's your fault
this guy's a [ __ ] genius how he
convinced her it's her fault they're not
married because i'm not the planner is
unfucking believable
there's literally a job called wedding
planner and he's convinced her that's
the issue
oh babe you really want to plan all that
come on let's just keep kicking this can
down the road i didn't think asians were
smarter than indians now i believe it
now i [ __ ] believe it
oh my god
you just gotta pick a date bro it's not
that hard hey you want watch this watch
this october 2022 i just planned your
wedding there you go real easy
i'm not the planner what do you do for a
living that better be [ __ ] incredible
i just switched to filmmaking
and this [ __ ] gonna be broke yo
you really [ __ ]
damn dude i want to see a movie about
this engagement
i bet you're gonna make the greatest
fiction movies the world has ever seen
five years of fiance that's a movie i'll
see
12 years of slave was a little too sad
five years of fiance
i'd be interested in that i'd be
interested in that one
oh good for you what do you do miss
and she got a real ass job dude
god damn man
i take it back you're the dumbest asian
i've ever met in my life you changed my
mind that fast this [ __ ] is an
idiot dude
that was the job that she fell in love
with that got to be a real job
health care doing what
ctm art were your radiologist
he's just throwing out letters like i
don't know about it i'm telling you i'm
not hurt but i'm not gonna believe
everything you say i'm gonna dig a
little deeper i'm an archaeologist of
your load of [ __ ]
[Music]
what is ct and mri you walk the
[ __ ] in the wheelchair to this
the mri
strap them into that [ __ ] machine and
go ahead don't panic i'll hold your hand
through this i'll be right here i'm not
going anywhere
son i've never been more of a feminist
in my life
i'm a big ass feminist right now
i'm on your side girl
listen if you ever have any questions
text me on the thread with my wife so
that [ __ ] don't get suspicious
[Music]
i've never been this excited to cause a
fight in my life
normally i'd be feeling bad i'm like ah
[ __ ] man i feel bad for this guy just
started a fight i'm so excited for this
one yeah i need to twist that [ __ ] i'll
livestream that fight
what's up guys thanks for watching the
video if you're a fan just hit subscribe
stop hating what are you waiting for
that way you'll get updated whenever i
put up new videos and we got a lot
coming after warranty
[Music]